FRED SAUER: I need a testing
strategy of App Engine
applications, as the SDK doesn't
implement all the
services exactly the
way that the
production environment does.
Do you have any insight about
how to test your applications,
taking into account some
of those differences?
MANDY WAITE: Yes.
So I guess testing--
there's a lot of ways
to do testing.
There's a lot of levels
you can do testing.
You can do unit testing,
functional testing,
integration testing.
Development testing is pretty
important of App Engine.
You really probably don't want
to deploy an untested version
or application, replace the
current version that's working
really well with one that's not
been tested particularly
extensively.
So, as always when testing in
the development environment,
it's probably important to mock
services that you can't
actually access directly.
FRED SAUER: Sure.
MANDY WAITE: So, in this case,
if there are any shortfalls in
what the development server
offers over what App Engine
offers itself, then you would
probably want to mock that.
So that will be the same with
accessing another API that you
don't want to access from
development, you may just mock
that service up, so you can
actually get reasonable
results from making calls
to that service.
You can probably do the same
with App Engine as well, any
App Engine services
that are missing.
Beyond that, really,
there's lots of
different options for testing.
Once you've deployed the
application, you may-- as Fred
has already mentioned, you may
deploy it to a different app
version, and then you may
use Traffic Splitting.
App Engine has this feature
called Traffic Splitting that
allows you to incrementally
direct traffic towards new
versions of your app.
So you can actually test the
thing in isolation to a
degree, only pushing a small
amount of traffic to it
initially, and then slowly
migrating all of the traffic
over as you get more confident
in the application's
performance.
And, again, also that other
kinds of testing, load testing
and suchlike, you don't really
want to do load testing on a
production application.
You would probably need to build
a different version of
your application before that
and do your testing on that
particular version of
your application.
You're also likely to need data
as well, so you need to
probably have a representative
set of sample data, you can
deploy your application.
If you have an empty datastore
it's not really going to give
you the exact same kind of
results that your production
application would do, so you
probably want to define a set
of data that you can actually
populate into your application
initially to do the
testing mode.
FRED SAUER: Yep, those
are very good points.
One thing that bites people a
lot of times when they're
testing in a different
application ID, or even on
their production application
before they launch, is people
will not use representative
workloads.
So instead of creating say 1,000
unique accounts, which
is sometimes tricky to do,
they'll say, OK we'll take 10
accounts, and we'll have each
one log in 100 times all
running concurrently.
And those access patterns
actually change the way the
data is utilized, and you don't
get very representative
results there.
So you already talked about
making sure that you have some
good sample data there.
Making sure you have good
representative requests and
users logging in.
It's kind of just
as important.
In any case, as much as you
can take the production
environment that you expect and
replicate it, the closer
you get, the closer
your results are
going to match, obviously.
MANDY WAITE: So you can use
tools [INAUDIBLE], like
Selenium and JMeter,
those kind of
things for load testing.
The same kind of tools you would
use for any kind of web
application to generate tests.
And they generate representative
workloads,
believe me.
FRED SAUER: They do.
Just watch out that you're not
testing from one machine that
just doesn't have a big enough
network connection.
MANDY WAITE: [INAUDIBLE]
Don't talk to me about
client side.
Because if your client can't
handle the load, then you're
never going to actually load
up the server the way you
think you are.
So you need to make sure you can
actually generate the load
correctly, you're not
[INAUDIBLE] over a lack of
client resources as well
when you're testing.
FRED SAUER: I guess you can
always get a few instances on
Compute Engine.
There's some capacity there.
Nice big pipe of data.